Mà mắt vừa chấp thộ một số nội dung quan trọng trung kế hoại khoa bình gà ra gồm 2 mi điểm của tổng thống Mi đường nân trang.
Đánh dân ở bước tháng đổi quan trọng chú lập trường của Phong Trần này,
hà mắt sẵn sàng đàn phán nếu lập tức về việc thả con tín, đồng thời khẳng định,
ông Hồ về chào quên của Li gà ra trong nhóm kỹ trị palestín đọc lập lập,
đếp được cộng đồng á rập huy sáo hổ thống theo hà mắt,
bây chức trả con tín sẽ cần tín thời gian,
giò khó khăn cho về tín kếm thi thế giữa các đường hành bị phá hủy.
Huyện có khoảng 2 mi người trên đồng số bố mi tảng con tín được chào là con sống.
Aïtập và cà ta đã hoàn nguyên tín điệu tích cựt từ hà mắt,
coi đây là cơ hội để thúc đẩy chăm dứt dùng đột.
Ngài sau tín bố, tổng thống đường đường trăm tiêu của Israel ngừng không tìm gà ra,
để bảo đam việc chào trả con tín diễn xa an tòàn.
Văn phòng thu tự tự Israel cũng khẳng đình,
sẽ phù hợp với Mỹ để tìm dài phát chăm dứt dùng đột phù hợp với lợi ek quốc cà hay bên.